in the very first chapter of A Song of
Ice and Fire and the very first sequence
of Game of Thrones we see mysterious icy
figures called White Walkers or others
at first we know nothing about them now
five books and five seasons later we
still know almost nothing but we do know
something so let's look at what we've
got and try to work out what the others
are what they want and what will happen
the others appear as white shadows in
the darkness tall and gaunt with bright
blue eyes they come when it's cold in
the night or else they bring the cold
and darkness when they come old man
calls them dead things
Sam calls them monsters and Sanus calls
them demons made of snow and ice and
cold but when once killed we see their
creatures made of blood and flesh and
bone George Martin has said that they're
not dead but a different sort of life
strange beautiful inhuman elegant
dangerous in the show the walkers looked
more or less like really old men with
wrinkled skin white beards black nails
and bad teeth either way the others
clearly aren't dead things or demons but
living creatures they speak in a
language of their own they laugh they
screech in pain in the show they show
shock and anger they make things out of
ice so the others are intelligent with
emotion and maybe culture they might not
be the monsters that they seem that said
they do a lot of killing
the others were rippling shifting Armour
that can make them near invisible and
wield strange pale swords so sharp they
can slice the ring mail as if it was
silk they fight effortlessly mercilessly
lightning quick and with a strength in
the show to throw men like ragdolls
their swords are so cold they shatter
steel and their armor protects them from
most blades they seem unstoppable but
they can be killed with obsidian also
called dragonglass
Sam stabs another with an obsidian
dagger and the Walker melts away its
fingers smoking where they touch
obsidian it's also hinted that Valyrian
steel swords can kill walkers and we see
this in the show Jon Snow's Valyrian
steel sword disintegrates another into I
see CGI others also apparently don't
like fire which probably means they'd
really hate dragons the others resurrect
the dead as of whites basically zombies
controlled by the others White's are
slow clumsy things with blue eyes and
cold black hands though in the show
there sometimes skeletal and fast
White's don't speak and seem to have no
humanity left though they seem to keep
some memories the others make whites out
of men women children and animals
Walkers bride dead horses
and aberrant about her land animator
Raven the others use whites to fight for
them and they are very dangerous white
seems stronger than living men able to
lift a man in the air by the throat and
near rip their head off him in a show
they tear through timber with their bare
hands they fall off a cliff and keep on
running they don't seem to feel pain
even losing their head won't stop them
and if a hand is cut off the hand will
keep moving unlike the others White's
aren't hurt by obsidian the only way to
stop them is to chop them into bits or
to burn them whites are really flammable
bursting into flame from even a little
touch of fire so one wait isn't too bad
but at the fist of the first men and at
hardhome in the show they come in a huge
swarm an unstoppable tide of the Living
Dead all controlled by the icy white
walkers
so what are the others want what are
they doing well they've been killing a
lot of humans in book 1 they kill some
wildlings and some men of the Nights
Watch and they send White's after the
Lord Commander enacting first Ranger at
Castle black in book 3 they used White's
to kill hundreds of nights Watchmen at
the fist of the first men
then Sam kills a walker and later
White's ascent after Sam and Gilly in
book 5 whites attack bran and company
and attack hardhome we also learned the
others have been attacking wildlings for
years forcing him to flee south and hide
behind the wall so the others are
killing humans of many different groups
on a large scale under building an army
of the Dead but that's not all they're
doing the wildling Craster refers to the
others as gods and has a sort of
agreement with them they don't attack
him and his wives and in return Krusty
gives them his male children leaving the
newborns in the snow to be collected by
the others in the show there's a scene
where another takes one across two sons
to a kind of an altar in what looks like
the far north land of always winter
there the baby is changed into what
looks like another one of Craster's
wives refers to the others as Christ as
sons so it looks like the others can
transform humans into others and that
some people give their children to the
others as a religious offering it's
probably not just crafter doing this
there are all sorts of strange waddling
cultures further to the north and some
of them are rumored to worship gods of
snow and ice sacrifice to the others may
be a widespread thing the word others is
used as a curse like a swear word and
the phrase is almost always the others
take you it's not the others kill you or
the others steal your stuff it is
sometimes the others bugger you but it's
almost always that others take you
suggesting that the others have a
history of taking humans we also hear
stories of waddling so would lay with
our others to birth half human children
which sounds like a different thing but
either way the others clearly don't just
want to kill humans but also want to use
them to make more others maybe that's
the only way the others can reproduce
maybe this is part of some kind of
natural cycle for now we don't know what
we do know is that the others are
killing people they're building an army
of the Dead and winter is come
melisandre says they're marshalling
their evil power and will wage a war for
life itself but they'll bring a night
that never ends
unless true men can fight them in a
great battle called the war for the dawn
Stannis calls the others the only enemy
that matters John calls them the real
foe and says they will come for us
everyone's expecting war between
humanity and the others which could make
sense because a war for the dawn has
apparently happened before we're told
legends of the long night a dark winter
thousands of years ago that lasted a
generation it said that in that darkness
the others came to extinguish all light
and warmth they swept over holdfasts and
cities and kingdoms felled heroes and
armies by the score riding monstrous ice
spiders and the horses of the Dead
leading hosts the slain when the realms
of men were almost at an end Westeros
was saved by the last hero who with the
help of the children of the forest who
might have given him obsidian
established the Nights Watch and
defeated the others in battle after this
victory the wall was built to make sure
that others could never come back so
that's the story in Westeros across the
Narrow Sea the Royer have legends of a
darkness but there's no mention of the
others or a battle in central assaults
the Dothraki in the cultures of slavers
Bay seemed to have no tales of the long
night but in the Far East their
religions very similar to the one of the
last hero and the battle for the dawn
the Yiddish say that during the long
knife they were attacked by the Lion of
night and his demons who were defeated
when a hero called azor Ahai forged a
burning sword and lead humanity into
battle now huge mysterious Citadel's
called the five thoughts stand to keep
the demons out dividing the realms of
men from the gray waste beyond which
sounds a lot like the wall right and the
demons of the line of night sound a lot
like the others isn't it super weird
that such similar things happened on
apparently opposite sides of the world
George Martin has said that his world is
round so if you went far enough east you
must eventually find Westeros
maybe these two places the freezing gray
waste and the land of always winter are
connected maybe there are others of
Westeros and the demons of eta1 and
same based in some place between the
wall and the five thoughts that would
make this area or a center of cold in
this world leading Valyria who are the
Targaryen sand apparently dragons come
from a center of heat this gives a sense
of order to the Fire and Ice in this
world and might explain why the long
night affected Westeros and UT so badly
without affecting central esos
apparently at all this could also be
related to the irregular seasons which
George Martin has suggested will
eventually be resolved somehow anyway
the main legends agree that the long
night ended with a battle led by a hero
now prophesied to be reborn and saved
the world once more which you know could
happen John snow could be reborn with a
flaming sword azor Ahai he could unite
the Nights Watch the wildlings in the
north and lead them to war killing
others with obsidian from the children
of the forest or from Stannis's mines
and Daenerys could fly in with her
dragons to burn away the dead and Tyrion
could ride one of the dragons and bran
could walk one of the other ones and
Rickon could write in on a unicorn and
all the good guys could come together
and kill all the bad guys and Daenerys
and John could make out and rule
together as queen and king as fire and
ice forever and ever the end except
things probably won't be that simple
does it really make sense for this story
to end with a war we've seen so much war
already and most of it achieves nothing
but suffering look at Robb Stark's
campaign Daenerys has conquests in
slavers Bay Stannis's invasion of
Blackwater Bay they're all seemingly
just wars waged by seemingly good people
but they all failed their original goals
and caused a huge amount of suffering
not just for the nobility but for the
common people look at is chapters at
Harrenhal
Jamie's chapters in the Riverlands at
Septon Mara bold speech were shown over
and over that war is terrible and wrong
and pointless George Martin himself was
a conscientious objector to the Vietnam
War
and many of his other books also have a
strong anti-war theme so how can a story
filled with terrible unjust pointless
Wars and with a Great War that saves the
world a war for the dawn would also be
too obvious George Martin has said that
part of the thing he always strives for
in his books is not to be predictable
and what could be more predictable than
the good guys defeating the evil ice
monsters in a big epic
Martin has specifically criticized the
Lord of the Ring style war between good
and evil he says we don't need any more
Dark Lord's we don't need any more good
guys battling bad guys the walls in my
books are much more morally complex
showrunner David Benioff has said it's
not going to be your classic good versus
evil conflict so the writer of the
series and the creators of the show as
well as the series itself make it clear
that this story won't end with a
righteous war between good guys and bad
guys which makes you wonder maybe that's
not what happened last time either
legends of the long night and the battle
for the dawn are ancient and weren't
even written down until thousands of
years after they supposedly happened
well weren't over and over not to trust
these tales so while the long night did
seem to have happened and the others
clearly at real the war for the dawn
might not have happened the way we're
told after all it's pretty hard to
believe that humanity could have
defeated the others who have seen how
dangerous they are
would a hero with a flaming sword have
been enough to win the war a popular
idea in the fair community is that the
long night ended with some kind of
peaceful agreement between humanity and
the others hints of this can be found at
the Nightfort the Nightfort is the
oldest and largest of the castles on the
wall
the Chiefs seat of the Nights Watch for
thousands of years now it's abandoned
and notorious as a haunted and dreadful
place it's a subject of horror stories
and strange legends some of which hint
at a connection between the Nights Watch
and the others this brings us to the
story of the night's king to clear
something up real quick this white
Walker in the show is referred to as the
night King by HBO but it's probably not
the same figure as the legendary night's
king at least not in the books so keep
that in mind but the story of the
night's king goes that thousands of
years ago the 13th Lord Commander of the
Nights Watch loved a woman with skin as
white as the moon and eyes like blue
stars which sounds like an other or a
wife he gave his seed to her and his
soul as well he proclaimed her a queen
and himself her king he bound his sworn
brothers to his will with strange
sorceries and ruled for 13 years until
the Starks and the wildlings joined
together to cast him down
it was then found that the night's king
had been making sacrifices to the others
which might mean giving them babies like
the night's king was doing this at the
Nightfort and the Nightfort just happens
to have a super creepy underground
hidden magic door called the Black Gate
that lets nights Watchmen through the
wall it's likely that the night's king
was using this sneaky door to make his
secret sacrifices and the thing is the
Black Gate is as old as the wall itself
why does the greatest and oldest of the
Nights Watch his castles its chief sake
that thousands of years have an inbuilt
sneaky hidden door to beyond the wall
maybe it had always been used for secret
sacrifice to the others there are
several other legends connecting this
castle to the others one about a hero
with suspiciously blue eyes and other
about a thing that came in the night it
definitely seems like some kind of shady
[ __ ] involving the others was going on
of the Nightfort in the early years of
the watch the HBO viewers guide hints at
a secret of the nine thought and this
secret may soon be uncovered because in
dance the Nights Watch starts to restore
the castle the habitation maybe they'll
find that the Nights Watch has a history
of sacrifice to the others and you've
got to wonder about the wall itself
we're told that it was built to keep the
others out after their defeat in the
battle for the dawn but why would you
build a wall made of ice to stop ice
creatures and how could it have been
built we're told that the first men cut
the ice from frozen lakes into huge
blocks dragged them along on sledges and
stacked them up into the wall can you
imagine how long that would take the
Great Pyramid of Giza took decades to
build that way and the wall is as long
as 2,000 great pyramids much taller -
even with the help of Giants the wall
would have taken centuries or millennia
to build doesn't it make more sense for
the others to have built the wall you
know the ice creatures who we know can
make things out of ice
the humans meanwhile could have built
the 19 castles along the wall the
structures that actually look like they
could have been built by humans
maybe the long night ended not with war
but with cooperation we know from crafte
that peaceful agreement between humans
and others is possible and we have
another precedent in the pact which was
a peaceful agreement between the first
men and the children of the forest after
their long horrible war under the pact
the children were given the forests and
the first man given everything
maybe similarly the humans and others
agreed to give the land north of the
wall to the others and the land south of
the wall to the humans a bit of sneaky
human sacrifice through the Black Gate
might have been part of the deal of
course if there ever was an agreement
between the humans and the others it
seems long for Godin now everyone's
gearing up for war but we actually have
the perfect hero to make peace possible
again Jon Snow is the Lord Commander of
the Nights Watch
he's been on or beyond the wall for
almost all the series and it's hinted
pretty explicitly that he has some
special destiny he probably has the
blood of the TUC Aryan Dragon Kings as
well as the stark kings of winter he may
be the prophesied azor Ahai and he's got
some definite similarities with Jesus
however you look at it John seems to be
the guy who will deal with the others
and the thing is John has a lot of
experience in making peace between
people's he spends almost all of dance
trying to reconcile the Nights Watch and
the wildlings to groups who hate each
other have been fighting for thousands
of years and seemed totally foreign to
each other but John works to achieve
peace anyway because he realizes it's
best for everyone
he tries to understand and sympathize
with the wildlings and similarly he
tries to understand the others he keeps
the whites for observation and get Sam
to research the others in the Castle
black library one of Stannis's knights
mockingly asks if Jon would offer the
others hospitality at the wall maybe
that'll actually end up happening John
is of course currently bleeding in the
snow with four stab wounds but he'll
probably be resurrected by Melisandre in
the other resurrections we've seen
people change when they come back from
the dead they seem to become less human
so maybe Jon will too
he'll certainly feel alienated from the
Nights Watch who betrayed him and he
might feel somehow closer to the others
his lifeline in dance says he never felt
the fourth knife only the cold Jon Snow
is someone special in his story he's a
hero and a bastard in black he's
honorable and he breaks his vowels he's
a son of a stark and probably a
Targaryen there's a duality in him a
meeting of Ice and Fire
which makes him perfect to make peace
between humanity and the others it won't
be easy
there'll be tough choices compromises
vices may be an uncomfortable marriage
but Jon Snow seems the perfect person to
do it so maybe when John is reborn he
won't be a warrior with a burning sword
but a different kind of hero a greater
kind of hero someone who worked not the
rule or destroy but to cooperate and
understand maybe John will bring peace
and balance to the world of Ice and Fire
we first saw the others in a game of
thrones nineteen years ago and we still
don't really know what they are and what
they're about but we can work some stuff
out the others are living creatures of
ice that resurrect the dead they're
dangerous they're killing people and
building an army of whites but they're
also using humans to reproduce so
they're probably not trying to wipe
humans out some expect a battle between
humanity and the others which has
apparently happened before but it would
make no sense thematically for the story
to end with war an alternative is peace
and there are hints of the night fort
and the wall that humans and others
somehow got along in the past Jon Snow
might be the perfect person to bring a
new peace that's one possibility anyway
for more theories and discussion you
might like to check out the a song of
ice and fire subreddit and the Westeros
for dog forums thanks for watching this
video was made possible by supporters on
patreon including xandria Leonard
stuffier vii rag doll Ralph Rainey's the
cat sovietwomble Florian Foster Gloria
is beam at Armstrong Paul Barry Theon's
favorite toy and sir Shire of house
LaBeouf for production updates early
access on a vote on the next video topic
you can support this channel at
patreon.com slash
old shift x Cheers